This is the Chris Abraham show.
Hey welcome back.
This is Chris Abraham.
Chris cast formerly known as but
now it's the Chris Abraham show
and it's windy here.
I don't know if you can hear me,
but I am doing this episode
season 5 episode 6 from the
Walter Reed Community Center
Park.
And I am right here at the
pickleball court.
So you might hear pickle bawling
in the background.
I would love to be a pickle
baller and I hope to become a
pickleball or this summer.
If not next spring, we'll save
maybe this fall.
Who knows?
Got to get into it.
But today's episode is going to
be about how when I can't
believe how long it's taken me
to figure this out, but Trump is
Lee are new.
And I know this might be so
obvious to you guys, but Trump
is America's 911.
Trump is America's 911 and like
the Patriot Act, it has enabled
America to behave extremely
badly.
Too extreme to act extreme to
behave, extremely, fistic,
extremely to tell latarian
extremely authentic.
Authoritarian and even extremely
despotically under the guise of
by any means necessary, right?
And it's the kind of behavior
that I don't even know how to
deal with because there have are
some people that I've idolized
my entire life, who have been
weaponized and who behaved so
badly with the understanding
that they are having a type of
democratic.
Jihad against against what they
consider to be.
All those things I just
mentioned, they're fighting
fascism with fascism.
They're fighting despotism with
despotism.
They're fighting to tell at
arianism with the totalitarian
ISM.
They're fighting identity
politics with identity politics.
And it is, there's no such thing
as a high road.
It's all low road, it's all this
understanding that while Jihad
exists, and while there are
enemies in our own country,
anything is acceptable.
As long as the war is won
against tyranny, this is a
terrible thing that's happening
because this has been a
conservative playbook for years
as well, right?
The conservative I guess I don't
even know but there's been this
idea of the second amendment
being a tool to be used in order
to fight off tyranny.
And there's this idea that
Christianity is being victimized
and in the same way that there
is a strong belief that Jews are
being Victimized in America.
There's also an increasing
belief that Christians are being
victimized, and of course, trans
people are being victimized in
Asian.
People are being victimized and
lgbtq people are being
victimized and gay people and
lesbians are being victimized
and women are being victimized
and everybody's being victimized
Trump in the interview with
Tucker Carlson on Tuesday night.
Spoke as though he was being
victimized both everybody in
associated.
With the January 6, Insurrection
is believes.
They're being victimized.
The people who were in Congress
in their day, believe that they
were literally literally killed
and assassinated, and hung, and
the people who were there,
They're believed that they that
they were being empowered and
just in order to be caught up as
victims in a kangaroo court, in
a false flag that was manifest
and weaponized.
Originally, just stay a protest
against what was considered to
be a Stolen election into being.
If you will a Lynch Mob that
literally killed Pence and hung
Pence, and killed dozens and
hundreds of police officers, who
up until that moment were the
evil.
Part of society are now
receiving Medals of Honor by the
same people who tend to want to
They were be being beatified on
one hand when it comes to
responding to January 6.
And then being demonized on the
other in response to Black lives
matter and other other
Progressive and Democrat Riot.
So everything's being
weaponized, everything's being
counter weaponized and I see
Trump, who's going to be
amazingly Successful at least
when it comes to primaries.
Is going to Jin everybody up.
And who knows there are?
There are no rules anymore.
People are very willing, I
believe to.
I mean I'm I'm surprised that
there and knock on wood, but I'm
surprised there haven't been
any, you know, any suicide
bombings.
I'm I'm surprised that there
haven't been any bomb vests.
I'm surprised that there's been,
no.
I mean, obviously the
transgender person who killed
six people in, In Tennessee last
week or so.
I'm pretty sure that has
resulted in a sort of de facto
martyrdom of the, of the person
who the trends person, who
entered the school and killed
Christian children and teachers.
I believe that that is going to
be painted as the first martyr
Adam against Crystal fascism.
So since there's no limit on
anything.
And since both sides are using
the totalitarian authoritarian,
And even like both sides are
using identity politics.
Both sides are using to radical
methodologies.
Everybody's using various and
Sundry CIA books for de stably
to stabilizing governments.
Gotta buy those things off of
CIA like everybody's using
playbooks from the color
revolutions domestically.
I mean, it's really exciting to
watch.
The only thing we don't have is
we don't have a Frenchman's
intensity, we do not have.
There are no Workers in the
streets.
There are no brawls between ride
control cops and, and normal
people who, you know, deliver or
or teach or any of that kind of
thing.
So, with that understanding, and
that lack of commitment to
taking the streets, and, you
know, the French have Twitter
and the French have Tick-Tock
and the French have Facebook,
Luffy's book and so forth.
There's no excuse.
We can't just say that were, you
know, stuck in a world where all
we care about is, you know,
Tucker Fox News or whatever,
like the French have Loop n,
right?
They have Marine Le Pen.
They've got blue pen, the Elder.
So, I mean, The only benefit we
have is everybody's waiting,
everybody's keeping their
powder, so dry, and everybody's
waiting for the whites of the
eyes, and everybody is just
locking and loading, and
prepping, and fidgeting and
nobody's doing anything.
The fact that America is at
least domestically all bark and
no bite has really benefited.
the burning down of of the
Cities, the burning down of the
Of the powers of control, right?
Like I personally think that
January 6 was a molehill, right?
Like there was no burning.
There was no permanent damage at
all, there was a little bit of
shit on the walls, a couple
broken things.
But to me it's not an
Insurrection until bodies are
piled up under the hail of
gunfire and the entire You know,
the entire Dome of the Capitol
building is incinerated from
fire or bums or or whatever,
right?
Until until the capital is
literally a reichstag.
It was really just just a
protest and some breaking and
entering, right?
So my expectation of domestic
Terrorism is bodies in the
streets.
My expectation for riots are
city blocks burnt to the ground.
My expectation for for all those
things are extremely much more
than your tolerance ones.
Tolerance Americans tolerance
for antisocial behavior is I
mean I mean, especially since
we're completely normalized on
hundreds of people dying every
labor and Memorial Day in
America in Chicago and the
streets of New York and streets
of DC, and so on and so forth.
So, there's literally There's
400 million privately owned
guns.
I'm jacking it to 400 million
because I'm not saying legally
owned guns.
Maybe 500 million guns in
general owned by people, whether
it's legal or illegal.
Any any altercation that looks
like it's going to be any
semblance of a, of a coup
d'etat, or anything like
sedition or anything, like an
Insurrection and so forth.
If there aren't bodies being and
not dying of Shame, three or
four or five or six or seven
days later from Strokes, or
Heart attacks or whatever,
right?
Not from the you humiliation, or
from being freaked out by the
news or any of that sort of
thing.
If, if the only person who dies
was shot in the face, Ashley
Babbitt being shot in the neck,
I'll be more precise being shot
in the neck by of fed through a
door, if that's the only
casualty and people aren't Being
you know stacked up like cords
of wood under hails of bombs,
burnings fires and the hail of
lead from gunfire.
Then it's just it's it's it's um
it's Hill & Knowlton, it's
Edelman its public affairs, it's
State Department.
It's It's CIA, its public
affairs from various and Sundry
groups, and I don't believe it
at all.
So we'll know when it's real and
I never wanted to be real.
I'm so happy that Americans are
in general either cowards or
unwilling to shit where we eat
or are just not nearly
uncomfortable enough or our
expectations are so low that we
are not willing to take to the
streets and and really make
people extremely uncomfortable
to the point where there's
either real, not figurative, but
real martial law and you know,
at least Echoes of Les
Miserables or Echoes of let them
eat cake or, or one legislator,
you know, in a world where
judges and lawyers are being
piled up like, like cords of
wood and Latin America and
around the world, the level of
anti-government behavior is
mostly verbal and I believe that
most of the active The active
antisocial behavior in the terms
of shootings and prevented
terrorist attacks, and other
domestic terrorist attacks in
the beginning when it was sexy
to be oppressive towards Islamic
Americans.
Muslim-americans, the feds
fomented mentally ill.
People into becoming radicalized
and I believe, you know, In the
world of, in the world, it's
called the six week cycle,
right?
Every six weeks, the FBI has to
do something.
That makes it implies that makes
it look like they are.
Earning their keep that the
Patriot Act deserves to be re
renewed and renewed.
And so, you know, the thousands
of see eyes and the thousands of
Of federal cops, go out there
and sting people into behaving
badly, and then stopping them
right before, blowing up a fake
bomb made of fake fertilizer.
So, so it's, you know, it's it's
it's Thea, it's its safety
theater, it's it's, um, It's
security theater.
It is a series of of It is a way
of controlling an uncontrollable
populace because as my spooky
friend agent KO, he says, you
cannot, you cannot control a
public.
That isn't willing to control
themselves, right?
It's been proven, you can't, you
can't make people who've signed,
nda's, not reveal things.
You need to make them afraid.
That if they reveal something,
they'll lose everything in a
world, in a modern world where
people have nothing to lose
because they don't own a house,
they don't have any kids.
They don't have parents that
they care about, they might not
even have a girlfriend.
They might not even have a
partner, they might be
completely alone.
They might be a They might not
even have a Brotherhood or a
fellowship or religion.
They might not have an
association with people who, you
know, in a world.
These are the people that are
often times recruited by Spire
organizations.
You know, if you aren't an
orphan but you live in orphans
life and you have nothing to
lose your extremely dangerous.
Luckily, these in cell people
tend to be extremely
conservative.
Cowardly as well, if you're
scared of your own shadow and
you're completely permanently in
a position where you are, are
convinced that you're the victim
and that you're traumatized, and
that your power is in your
vulnerability, then you're not
going to do anything, right?
And if you're afraid of guns and
frayed of anything like that,
then you're not going to arm
yourself.
And if you are completely
balkanized, you're not Going to
be a jointer either.
You're not going to join any
group you and if you're
completely sure that there's a
pen Opticon over, all male
groups, including Catholicism
and Christianity.
And Islam, if you believe that
there is ubiquitous AI digging
into every corner.
Like they couldn't get into, you
know, the Like, they couldn't
get into the what is it called?
The server like, nobody's
watching anything right there.
In fact, there's so much.
Ubiquitous panopticon ISM that
nobody can track anything.
Doing anything.
Everybody can figure out what
happened after a crime happened,
but there's no way like
pre-crime is a pretty much an
inexact science and it's not
small.
It's not a small world after all
anymore.
But like my buddy Agent K said
to me, he's like, there's not a
one-to-one ratio, right?
The Stasi did an amazing job of
turning all children into narcs
and turning all neighbors into
narcs and to turning all old
people into narcs and to making
sure that people were not allies
with their Or their parents or
their children that they realize
that the value and power.
And righteousness of the state
transcends, the concept of
snitches get stitches, right?
That's the constant libertarian
ethos that the state of America
if it's going to become a maoist
socialist, Utopian future one
needs to seed the trust from
that of in God that of family
and that of community and not
come from an ethos of snitches
get stitches.
But what is the term?
If you see something, say
something that, the only way we
can keep things safe is if You
actively hammer down the
protruding nails, so, so there's
that, like I do not believe I do
believe that there's lots of
people dying in the city's inner
cities, but I say that when it
comes to gun crime, I don't
include suicide.
In terms of gun crime.
If you, if you, if your crime is
only against yourself, then it's
not criminal and I don't believe
that.
It suicidal people are
criminals.
I do not believe that suicide is
a criminal Behavior.
I do not believe that committing
suicide is morally.
Even morally, uncool, I believe
that anybody who wants to check
out, you know, especially if
they believe their brain is
broken and they don't feel like
they fit anymore and they've
been When I mean, you know it's
a three-strike rule, right?
Like if you if there's been
interdiction on your tendency to
want to be suicidal, and you've
been, and there's been an
interdiction on your or an
intervention on your behavior
several times.
And you are Inconsolable then
your decision is your own and
you know, nobody man.
Even dated a girl, pretty
recently who scrolled up.
She doesn't do it anymore but
she she squirreled away.
What she called.
Her magic yellow pills, right?
Like they helped her sleep, but
she also Squirrel them away and
made sure that she had a death
dose, right?
A fatal dose.
There's a lot of people who do
that like recently a family
friend took her life via hanging
which is an extremely aggressive
personal act, right?
Like there's no it's a painful
thing, right?
Like unlike a professional
hanging, which is in a Gallows
where you fall 10 feet, and
break your neck.
This is something where you fall
maybe off of a stool and it is
100%, it is 100% asphyxiation,
God, right?
I mean, I believe that you
should be allowed to take your
own life.
I don't believe that the numbers
of people who take their own
life by a firearm should be
included in the number of gun
crime deaths in America.
That said there are 400 500
million legal and illegal guns
in America.
Maybe even a billion and The
restraint that garden-variety
Americans have in their
day-to-day.
Considering that, I think that,
you know, most of these
shootings are federal setups.
I mean, obviously school,
shootings, and so forth.
You know, are less suspect, but,
you know, things where people
things are discovered in the
nick of time in though, so
forth.
Like considering that there
might be short of a billion
firearms in this country and 783
or similar 93 million privately
owned legally.
No, sorry, sorry, I take that
back.
Three hundred three hundred
eighty three or three hundred
ninety.
Three million privately owned
legal firearms.
I would say that this is a
country of extreme amounts of
Restraint, right?
Like it's not like the movies
where cops are going into the
streets after a bank robbery and
mowing down using fully
automatic AR-15s and machine.
Pistols or ubiquitous Miami Vice
Uzi or Ingram 10 or Ingram 11
or, you know, canine is that
right?
Or the ubiquitous MP5.
Nine millimeter or the sexy
little 380 Scorpion or 32
Caliber Scorpion CZ.
Scorpion like this is not this.
There are, it looks like
according to the media, there
might be more and more full auto
Glocks.
Now, that seems to be popular
using the third party
chinese-built Seer called, I
think they call it a Nora or
something.
There seems to be more of that,
but I've never heard it.
I've heard gunshots, I live in
the greater DC area.
I've never heard burp, burp,
burp.
What up, what up?
I've never heard bursts of
three.
I've never heard full-auto in
the streets.
I've only heard some automatic
guns fire, so, I don't even
know.
Did I stop this at all?
Or did I do an introduction?
Who knows?
Anyway, yeah, I think I'm done
but I do think the the the
source of this conversation is a
lot to do with what I was saying
before, which is to say now that
everything has become so life or
death and you know there's then
9/11 might have been against
against might have allowed Jihad
against the Muslim world or
against the Middle East or
against Afghanistan or this
thing called terrorism.
The One is is a Jihad against
Americans, right?
And and the biggest danger
though is that anybody who
proves extreme can end up under
the extremists under the
extremists Spyglass some of the
the the microscope, right?
You if you are If you are
antifa, you are not immune you
are tomorrow's Target, right?
You there might be a Cristo
fascist focus at the moment.
But in a world where by any
means necessary, it means that
anybody who takes You know, this
is not a sweet generous, this is
not a self-defined mission, this
is a a larger command and
control hearts and command and
control hearts and mind mission.
Right?
So this isn't just BLM this
isn't just Trends right?
So this isn't just lgbtq or this
just this isn't just pro-choice
or pro-life and this isn't just
that Min ISM against Key like no
matter what the situation this
will be as shape-changer that
will always change its shape in
order to foment and exacerbate
and can certify and mutate.
And what is the term for
malignant, fi anything that will
distract stabilize the
government in a way that there
can be better control over the
populace and the populace can be
coerced or manipulated and even
better than that decide to.
Because going back to Agent K,
it's much better.
If the people the people who
follow think they're the
leaders, it's much better.
If the sheep and I hate to use
that word or it's much better
when the flock already knows
where to go.
Go.
So that the, so that the
shepherd doesn't have to work so
hard and And so you know what's
going to happen if by any means
necessary, what is the next?
What are the next?
What is the next 18 months going
to look like right?
Like I assume that there's just
about 18 months between now and
the election?
And I want you to know that
Trump is always been a foil.
Trump is always been a
manifestation of something.
He's always been trumped up,
he's always been a trump card,
he's always been someone who is
a what is the term?
A Goldberg from 1984.
He's a, he's a, he's a, he's the
manifestation of a false flag.
He's the manifestation of, they
of Boogeyman, he is a
manifestation of a Hitler of a
Mussolini of a now, of a Stalin
of a Lenin of a, of a, Of a
despot like charge Fescue or
whomever like he is he is
America's Putin, right?
He is the heel in a wrestling
match.
He is the, he is the wrestler ug
rat, while the face and I assume
that the face is Joe Biden. the
face comes out swathe, in an
American flag and while in comes
the evil, Devious terrifying.
Monstrous caricature that is
That is that is Donald Trump.
Donald Trump leans into his
caricature.
Donald Trump has never tried to
remake himself into anything but
a reduction of Donald Trump.
He is, he is the he is the low
class version of the Monopoly,
man, right?
He is.
He is the Monopoly, man.
And with a bad 10, bad dye job
and zero spectacle zero spats
zero-waste Coast, 0, Whitetail
Blacktail black tuxedo, right?
He is the floppy-haired 1980s
villain in any sundry movie
where some douchebag sleeps with
your wife.
Wife.
For closes your your house.
Destroys your credit and fires
you.
So, all that said, this is going
to be fun to watch if there are
no rules during a time of jihad,
I'm surprised that things
haven't gotten much more
terrifying.
I think that a periodic school
shooting is nothing. 1969. 1968,
they burnt down Washington d.c.
they burnt the fuck.
In place down, not, not just a
couple cop cars, but they burnt
down what most of you street,
right?
When I started college in 88
here, like that whole
neighborhood was still POS man,
still not smoldering literally,
but smoldering figuratively.
Anyway, I thought I'd go ahead
and record a very sweet and
loving and kind and generous
Blog podcast to keep everything
light and uplifted and I'll talk
to you soon.
Love you guys.
Bye.
Thank you for listening to the
Chris Abraham show.
Make sure you subscribe.
So you don't miss any future
episodes until next time.